my name is Jean-Pierre true CEO of mbu
I'm a licensed architect and interior
designer with over 20 years experience
in architecture and the construction
industry
and I'm Michael Wharton nice to meet you
all I'm I've got a background in
aerospace engineering computer science I
actually went to school here back in the
day but since then I've done a lot of
work with remote sensing some some work
in the Aerospace industry as well as
artificial intelligence Consulting so
excited to talk to y'all yeah we're very
excited for this talk about building a
better world with AI one architectural
drawing at a time so you guys excited
you guys want to start let's do it all
right awesome well let's talk a little
bit about our our industry if you think
about anything about the construction
industry the first word that comes to
mind what what do you think it is
just throw me something think about
Construction
permits yes terrible right old yeah yeah
archaic very old as well the oldest
Industries you know has much change code
yes we're gonna address that
sir
yeah you're cheating you're cheating
your titty uh but yeah if you think
about if you look in the past throughout
history really not much has changed from
how we built back then and will be built
now but there has been a lot of progress
in the advancements of Technologies in
adoption of new new methods and and
Technologies like 3D printing and now
we're seeing tremendous excitement about
AI
especially in the architecture in the
architecture side there's a tremendous
excitement in generative design tools so
if you think about
you know anything that could help with
the design process right so there's this
excitement about you know text to prom
image generators like me Journey Dolly
and staple diffusion that creates this
really amazing evocative
um images of what architecture could be
in the future to the most practical
application where we can see Automation
in feasibility studies or be able to you
have a site and you have several
parameters that you want to do a
mixed-use project with multi-family and
a portion of it is office it brings you
a hundred to a thousand different
iterations of what you can put on that
side or you want to move to a new office
building and you can generate thousands
of different test bits depending on your
program for your business right you have
X amount of conference rules private
offices open offices and stuff like that
but the most critical aspect of our
profession
the quality control
remains overlooked
wait quality controls that's the most
important aspect of our profession can
you imagine a world
without quality control in construction
right so I'm looking at the image on the
left in here
somebody really took literal of my plans
and when and carved out a very precise
cloud-shaped hole in the slab
right so for those of you don't get this
joke because this is a little bit tricky
clouds depict changes
so if I draw a cloud in a drawing I'm
telling you hey check it out something
has changed in here so please don't
carve a hole in my slab
um I want to give up to the guy right in
the middle I mean at what point
at what point somebody just said hey
there's something wrong in here man it's
like are you sure the column's going
here and this is where we egress so
imagine you are like in a fire or
something you know or like it's midnight
and you want to get to your apartment
um somebody really wait a long time to
bring that up to the architect in the
Builder but my favorite one I Gotta Give
It to the guy or whoever decided hey if
this store doesn't open don't worry I'm
gonna cut it to shape perfectly you know
no not switching the door or maybe like
stuff hey do we get this thing wrong
let's cut it the shape and see if that
works
all right so now you guys understand
what quality control is important
the problem with quality control is that
it lacks automation so you have you know
very experienced Architects and and
Builders and Engineers sitting in
conference rooms reviewing hundreds and
thousands of pages
it relies on human review
is extremely painstaking and repetitive
and time consuming I spent over 30 to 40
percent of my time seeing in a
conference room reviewing hundreds of
thousands of pages
I'm very good at what I do but I steal
mistakes not like the ones that we saw
but I still do
and those mistakes has a significant
Downstream economic impact on the
project
and those if you think about it like the
AIA which is the American Institute of
Architects did a study and they found
that the best set of construction
documents out there has 95 percent
accuracy this is like the best like
being reviewed to the I mean to the
single note in the in the drawing 95
percent
that means on a 20 million dollars you
can inspect at least a million dollars
in mistakes
I was just trying to find a mistake in
here in this room I found that that
diffuser right there supposed to be
flushed to that
to that uh wall so you see right there
next to the exit sign it happens all the
time
all right so how tedious can be this
process jump here well try to find five
different things I'm gonna time you five
different things between these two
simply you found one already you're
smiling
did you guys plan at least one
congratulations
he has did it now let's try on 200 pages
200 pages of technical drawings multiple
disciplines
pair with uh Bible side of text that
tells you everything from how you
procure materials to how you submit
those materials for approval the
warranties you need to provide I mean
you name it is extremely tedious and
this is my product as an architect
engineer or Builder right this is my
product because this is what carries all
my liability
we use all this technology to build this
amazing projects and you think that oh
the product of the architect is those
amazing images that you showed me on the
first slide
that Vision no
my ears and emissions and insurance is
this this is what carries all my
liability and that's what I need to
review what has my stamp
so you have in this set of drawings
different multiple disciplines you have
architecture structural mechanical
electrical Plumbing MVP landscape civil
and a set of specifications that we
talked about that
so now that you can understand
why it's important and how teach you it
is why hasn't been automated and solved
well I'll tell you Jean Pierre let's do
this tell me why it hasn't yeah you're
probably wondering why someone like me
with a background in computer vision and
deep learnings linking up with someone
like Jean-Pierre here it's got Decades
of experience in architecture
it's because you know the time's kind of
ripe to solve this problem you know you
with a little bit of training can look
at an architecture drawing with its you
know it's it's friend that's a little
bit newer a little bit revised and
compare them and perceptually you can
you can see what's different you can see
are there more toilets now did a wall
change Dimension
um did it is the drew the drawing view
the exact same but it actually moved
across the page it's pretty easy for you
as a human to tell this
um but it turns out until very recently
it's been very very difficult to train
computers to do something like this
right they're very small details that
are difficult to catch and it's
especially challenging with architecture
drawings because you're talking about
you know sometimes tens of thousands of
pixels just so in width just so you can
have enough fine-grained detail that you
can pick up really really small details
that turn out to have really large
financial implications on the final
build
um so yeah like I said until very
recently it's been impossible to look at
this and figure out perceptually what's
going on in in cases like this but
time's right so
and I think a good way to illustrate
this is to look right yeah let's switch
Let's Do It
um a good way to illustrate this is just
look at this comic the date on this from
XKCD I'm sure y'all have seen XKCD
Comics
um it's 2014 and you might not be able
to read the text but essentially what's
happening is there's an analyst and
someone asking questions and they're
asking hey here's a photo
um can you tell me whether it was taken
in a national park and analysts like
sure give me a few hours I'm gonna go
look up a GIS database and figure out
where this photo was taken because
that's probably what you would have done
at the time and then the next question
is can you tell me if it's a photo of a
bird and it's like yeah give me a
research team and and years and years to
figure this out because at the time
that's what it would take to answer a
question like that now all of you I'm
pretty sure if or at least some of you
probably have iPhones and you can go in
your photos and just search with text
like find me photos of birds or photos
of my friend or whatever and it can
actually do things like that so
Technology's there and it's very very
recent that we've had this in our
toolkit this is how crazy fastsf move
things
yeah it's pretty wild you know back in
89 there was this research lab that I
think was trying to do
um trying to detect digits of zip codes
in those forms I'm sure you all filled
out tax forms it's tax season you get
the little boxes you put in your ZIP
code they built a convolutional neural
network and it was handcrafted
painstaking took a huge research team to
figure out how to do this and they were
largely successful but they also didn't
have the accelerated compute that we
find ourselves having today and then in
98 Yan lacun came up with this
architecture that started to really
really hone that and it started to use
this algorithm called back propagation
which I'm sure some of you have also
heard of that is used to train these
convolutional neural networks with
training data instead of having humans
have to having to craft exactly what all
these numbers are that go into these
networks and sometimes you have
thousands millions in the case of large
language models billions of parameters
you you can't put all the humans in the
world in there to craft this thing
because it's just unfeasible
and then finally in 2012 this Alex net
came out and that was the Catalyst point
where there's this historical Benchmark
called imagenet
and that is this database of millions of
images they're all hand labeled you know
they have birds do they have cars or
people in them it's just these common
classification labels and the goal is to
just get as accurate as possible you
build a model that takes in this mod an
image and then predicts what's in it
and at this moment when they release
this architecture it blew the original
accuracy I think it's top five accuracy
out of the water
it added something like 10 percentage
points to the accuracy and that is
unheard of in our business you know it's
a lot of times you have a team of people
trying to just eke out an extra half a
percent here and there and to see
something like that is a pretty big step
change
and then all of these innovations that
have come out since then have always
step change kind of change the state of
the art and we're now in this land now
where we have the ability to with
computers do perceptual tasks
with um you know without a human in the
loop so it's a pretty great time
and then yeah just in terms of what
these things are doing under the hood
you know you have like I mentioned
anywhere between thousands to billions
of parameters and you present this
network with a bunch of uh images with
their Associated labels you say you know
is it a bird is it a koala bear in this
case and then there are these Special
Operations you do to to look for you
know the higher levels of these Networks
you're looking for really basic things
like you know lines or certain kind of
curves or generally things that are very
local and simple and as you get deeper
and deeper in these networks you know in
some cases on these networks that are
looking at humans
there's a single number inside there
that'll tell you if they're wearing
glasses or not
so it's really really cool and really
exciting and um we figured you know why
the heck wouldn't we just take some of
this technology and apply it to
architecture yep so how we're tackling
this problem
so these are what I call the pillars of
the Quality Control process when I'm
sitting and looking at a set of drawings
I'm looking for the perspective of
graphics and annotations making sure
that every single drawing and detail is
perfectly drawn and is coordinated
healthy enough information that I can
depict what I'm trying to build
change control as design progresses
there's changes that constantly happen
and those changes have implications
let's see I move a wall I need to also
make sure that the detail for that wall
has been updated and the cross
coordination aspect of it doesn't impact
you know the mechanical uh in here for
example right so this relationship
between this diffuser and the wall has
some codependencies so if I change the
ball there's a correlation and things so
that's cross coordination in this case
I'm giving you example of the location
of the structural element the the column
is the same in the architecture drawings
as is in the structural and that's
critical you'll be surprised there's a
lot of issues on site because of that to
Code Compliance somehow most of us have
been familiar with some type of code
right it changes or do jurisdictions if
you're doing a house remodel or anything
so it's extremely it's extremely complex
itself and like I said is it sense of
multiple jurisdictions and different
types of codes City of Austin has a
plethora of codes that I have to review
constantly and they keep changing too so
and then completeness check to making
sure that you have all the documentation
in order to accurately price permit and
build a project
so now that we understand
you know all the different things let's
focus on one in particular let's focus
on uh the Change Control aspect and how
we're tackling that let's dive deeper
into that that sounds good and yeah for
the record I've seen some of these uh
code books that he mentioned before I've
seen him slam on the table the whole
room starts shaking everyone around
turns around see what happened
it's it's pretty bad I don't I don't
envy your job no that's the least part
of the job that I like but it's okay
yeah
um but yeah so there so like I mentioned
I mentioned classification tasks earlier
but there are all sorts of tools there's
a there's a family of deep learning
algorithms that really help us out here
with with the task at hand and one of
those is something called object
detection
I'm sure you've all seen some videos
where if you're watching a tennis match
or a soccer match or football if you're
from Peru yeah
um but yeah you you know you'll see a
box that's drawn around players around
balls and you see it kind of get tracked
around for a single frame the task of
drawing those boxes around the parts
that you're really interested in that's
what object detection is
and it turns out that we can do that
pretty reliably with these architecture
drawings as well let's say you want to
do something simple like count how many
toilets are in a page and maybe they're
you know a ton of them and for a human
it would take a really long time you
could do one forward passive of a
network that you've trained on documents
right and you can answer that question
in a matter of seconds or less so
and this is a great example of some of
the things that we might pull out or be
interested in you know if you can
imagine looking at this and kind of
pacing it apart you have an original
document and a revised one there's so
much detail in here to figure out as a
human with your eyes that it would take
you some anywhere from minutes to I
don't know days to figure out what are
the actual important differences between
these what doesn't matter what kind of
action items do I need to take from that
and if we can use these techniques to
enrich these documents and figure out
okay where are the doors
where the where's the furniture where
these appliances you can piece apart
piece it apart and kind of parse
everything and it sets you up for
Success when it comes to change control
and he has semantic information you know
everything yeah yeah the context is
actually very important so not only are
we looking for specific objects that we
care about but the relations between
them are also really important like the
Code Compliance examples John parrot
just told us about
um but maybe so with this box Fidelity
that we're looking for maybe it's not
enough maybe we need to actually know
what regions are important to us
um so that for that we would use
something called semantic segmentation
this is a network here that's built on
the same technologies that that other
one that I mentioned that kind of blew
image that out of the water
same basic building blocks just meant to
serve a different purpose but let's say
we wanted to try to predict how much
square footage is in this floor plan and
maybe some change has happened there are
a lot of changes structural elements
changed floor has changed you want to
just figure out something simple like
how much did the square footage change
right that's a really hard question to
answer sometimes you need a team of
people but with semantic segmentation we
can do that
yeah and here's just an example of the
same kind of elements we were interested
in before but with the semantic
segmentation layer applied
um you know all sorts of different
interesting use cases there
and then furthermore I mean we got these
line segments that are also interesting
you might be wondering
you know that seems kind of silly why
would you need line segments separated
and why would that matter but it matters
a lot especially if you can classify
them right um you know we're interested
in actual structural elements of the
document where the doors how big are
they how do they compare between
versions but also these these
annotations are really important maybe
you want to figure out there's a little
you know a group of texts that has an
arrow pointing to something we want to
figure out what does that group of text
mean from a natural language standpoint
where are the line segments that are
joining that relevant piece of text and
something that it's pointing to I mean
maybe it's saying some specification
about a materials changed it's a simple
note like that if we can understand it
might have tens of thousands to maybe
even millions of dollars of impact on a
design and without a team of people that
are analysts that are experts you just
wouldn't know that really readily and
just on that note alone is the ability
to understand when you are making
changes what actually constitute a
change so if if now if you're looking at
the node with a leader line and it
starts telling you okay I just move the
node graphically the arrow is still
pointing at the same location is is that
a change so we're building intelligence
to also interpret those changes the same
way that I am looking at it in the
drawing so for me that is not a change
because the content hasn't changed and
also the point that the arrow hasn't
changed the location so it would make
more sense once we go
table parsing yeah table Parson is
another great one
um you know it's routine that tables
contain really important information
that you need in context to figure out
what the rest of the drawing means maybe
there's a certain code or something
check me on this but maybe like you have
a code that specifies a material right
and it's Unique there and you need this
extra metadata to figure out why is that
important where does it apply and if you
can't parse these tables to figure out
these key value pairs these rows
information figure out you know what
these headings mean subjectively yeah
then
you know you're you're missing important
information that prevents you from being
able to do full change control here
um and then just a couple you know I
mentioned this one inflection point I
would I would guess that this one in
2012 there is right that's the one that
corresponds to that Alex net
architecture we were talking about
earlier but you know back in the 90s I'm
sure you've all heard the term heuristic
uh hurt sorry expert systems
those heuristic rules-based models if
you've if you've done any amount of
software engineering you know that you
get some sort of Baseline level of
accuracy and then you start to get to
this territory of like whack-a-mole
where you make one change and it fixes
something over here but then something
else breaks yeah and you're kind of at
this asymptotic place where you can't
make your thing better no matter how
hard you try well in computer vision
specifically these deep learning models
allowed us to just break past that in
2012 and then more recently the thing
that allows us to have great things like
gpt4 and all these big large language
models that you've you've heard about
underneath that is this technology
called Transformer models and you know
at first they didn't do very well with
computer vision but then Vision
Transformers came on the scene and now
we do have them providing at least a
little bit of extra value in addition to
these Baseline architectures that we've
used for years now so it's really just
an exciting time to be part of this
field
so where we are on Change Control we
have applied all these techniques and we
are able to compare two set of drawings
currently and identified everything that
has changed
and to a level that is far superior and
more accurate than a human the problem
is
is very accurate
and it doesn't have that
you know understanding of what A change
is a change or it's not a change so
graphically that takes everything right
so then we're teaching it you know to
what actually what are the set of rules
that constitute a change I use the uh
the uh example of the leader line you
know if it's still pointing at that
chair and he's saying it's a chair and I
haven't changed the text it's not a
change right no matter where that node
is on the plan but now we're also moving
towards telling what has changed so in
this case we're showing that there's
been remember oh remember the cloud that
we saw originally what a cloud means
don't cut it please it's a revision
right okay so that's a revision here so
I'm identifying what has changed in this
drawing so in here now we're telling
added a structural element new concrete
being eight inches by 36 inches and as
the AI evolves is also identifying the
code potential code violation that we're
not meeting a certain clearance so in
terms of
you know installing any type of
equipment that has some requirements
from a clearance standpoint to code
requirements you will start to telling
you uh as as you actually review the
drawings
and from a product Evolution right now
mbu is a web-based application
we're using AI to instantly review to
your drawings it's if you know how to
attach the
um an attachment on an email you know
how to use mbu you just upload your
first set of drawings and the one that
you want to compare and instantly you
get a a review and we're moving towards
the next uh wearing beta right now we
have working with 10 customers
construction companies that we're
testing this technology right now it has
a tremendous value because they're
tracking changes as a part of the
construction process and we are
introducing new models like natural
language processing and reducing false
positives right now so in terms of false
positives what I mean is like okay we
built a model that's very accurate but
is it smart enough that understands what
is specifically what different changes
you can find so we are reducing that we
are identifying changes in text you
remember that set of specifications that
just to give you an idea I just did a
office building and burn it by the
Torchy's Tacos there in North Burnett
5209 Burnet it's called or Victory plaza
it's a 90 000 square foot office
building
took me a whole week to review those set
of drawings that I showed you that
picture took me a whole week review on
and we can do that in the near future
instantly
so it's a tremendous amount saving
tremendous amount of time and money and
reducing significant amount of liability
for Architects and Builders so this is
the amazing thing that we that we are
are building and we'll be moving from
the two document comparison because
right now that's what we we can do we
identify from A and B what has changed
going back to that image that you find
super fast I was super impressed how
fast you found five different things on
those images
we're doing that instantly and we're
moving to a single document review which
we don't need to see the previous
version because we understand how the
project evolves and we can review the
same way that you send me your drawings
and I'm looking at it on a conference
room it can do it uh instantly
this is the application again wearing
beta right now you upload a set of
drawings
and you get your comparison and this is
what you get this is the output
so going back again the clouds telling
you everything that has been changed or
have been detected
you get a side-by-side comparison so you
see it from the previous version you can
tell that the drawing in here has been
deleted and there's some information
missing in here
um there's a change on this table of
content in here on on
your specification
and a cloud and uh column has been added
as well
and then you get a div file as well so
you can see side by side on overlay
simple div file that you can easily
identify uh what has graphically changed
so this is uh currently in beta and
thank you so much for the time
thank you